is it an homage to Britney Spears at the
VMAs or did you just feel like wearing a
snake today I honestly just felt like
wearing a snake today but then somebody
reminded me that Britney had the snake
so I was like you know what I'm gonna
say it's a homage but is snake coming
with you all night just for the red
carpet how does this work she might be
with me all night I don't know she's I
love snakes I have them at home so I
like to bring them as much as possible
if I can the VMAs this energy is
incredible do you feel it this is old
hat for you now oh my gosh this is my
first time here at the VMAs
so the energy is so much different it's
so explosive and exciting and there's
all these people out here I mean I've
seen everybody so I'm having a really
great time and so is Big Mama here
there's a lot of speculation about Super
Bowl this year and if it's gonna be in
Miami have you heard anything I have not
I'm curious let's see where that goes
would you ever be interested in popping
up on the Super Bowl stage I don't know
I you know I've been a little busy
lately so I don't even think I have the
time you know I'm preparing to drop my
new album so I've been like heavy heavy
in the studio as much as possible and do
you feel the pressure after the success
of the last one that took you all the
way to superstardom a little bit it's
kind of tough you know it really it
wasn't even considered my first album
but it kind of turned into that and so
you know I'm trying to block it out and
just be me because that's why people
love the first one because it was
totally me
yeah do you know anything about the
snake this is Big Mama yeah she's a ball
python yeah she's sweet you can touch
her Big Mama oh well she's beautiful
okay well I've got like five snakes at
home though ever thought of you as a
snake person I am you just never know
I'll put the idea you were stylist me
yeah I saw the snake on the outfit I was
like a perfect accessory and you tried
one at home and you're like okay it'll
work and let me get me a working snake
exactly exactly exactly thank you so
much it's great to see you looks so
pretty
[Music]